foreign  hello Mrs Turner  you talk about this  we lost Jericho when he was  13 weeks Dorothy took it hard this was  the only thing that brought her back  any questions  no Mr Turner  whose baby is that  did I do something wrong do you know  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  you told her what she did  we have to protect ourselves  you have to understand  for Jericho there is nothing I wouldn't  do nothing  be best if we were able to make tea  smoothly yeah why aren't you both so  afraid of her I don't know why I keep  doing that things  I didn't feel the dark thing in me  getting bigger I know they're coming for  me  I'll be ready  [Music]  she grows stronger each night the house  is filled with paracet  smell The Rock  what the hell happens now  [Music]  the end  you can feel it though can't you  it's a power  there's a war of foot  and there's nothing any of you can do to  stop me  [Music]